Now, classical conditioning explains a lot of our behaviors. But only our
reflexive behaviors. Things such as salivation, and our startle response. So
how do get the more complicated behaviors that we engage in? Well, we do so
through what's called operant conditioning. Now, B.F Skinner started the field
of operant conditioning. And he had the idea that we operate on our
environment. And our behavior is selected from the environment, meaning, if we
engaged in the behavior and something positive happens from that, we're likely
to do it again in the future. However, if we engage in a behavior and something
bad happens, we're less likely to do that again in the future. So with operant
conditioning, we have our large muscles in being involved instead of our just
reflexive behaviors. Let's go into this in a little more detail.